3000 abonnenten oder knapp 3000
abonnenten und auch ihr partner und eine
partnerschaft hey leute was geht ab und
jetzt willkommen beim ein video jahre
alt ich hoffe natürlich getrübt dieses
video entsteht mal wieder sehr spontan
irgendwie ich habe ja gerade so ein
bisschen semesterferien und eigentlich
sollte heute wieder kein video kommt
liegt dann allerdings so vor mir um das
sagt man glaube ich nicht so aber ich
hatte heute wäre ich komplett den ganzen
tag nichts zu tun einfach mal komplett
freizeit und dann hat mir dann mein
erstes wieder mal angeschaut bzw bin
drauf gestoßen und mir ist aufgefallen
ich bin der einzige youtuber deutschland
glaube ich der nicht wenigstens einmal
auf sein erstes video reagieren weil ich
meine ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
habe das schon ewig nicht mehr
angeschaut das video müsste ich ungefähr
vor drei oder vier jahren auf youtube
hoch gestellt haben da war ich 15 oder
16 höchstens und ja ich würde sagen das
schauen wir uns heute mal zusammen an
ich sage echt noch ziemlich süßes aus
und auch anders obwohl ich da immer noch
süßes oder nicht war es aber es gab hier
von mir auch öfter einmal videos wo ich
mir alte videos von mir angeschaut habe
allerdings hat sich dann dabei um
irgendwelche videos gehandelt die schon
gar nicht mehr online sind und die auch
nie auf diesen channel online waren
sondern irgendwas wo ich zwölf war oder
so ja deswegen wollen wir eigentlich gar
nicht lange lagern
ich mache mir hier kurz die
bildschirmaufnahme an wenn man hier ein
gibt alex wie erstes video kommt man auf
mein nicht mein erstes video so dann
machen wir das einmal anders wir gehen
hier über videos sortieren alt nach neu
und jetzt müsste ich eigentlich in mein
erstes wir haben genau zwanzig facts
about me blockbuster ohne witz wer von
euch ist schon dabei seitdem ich noch
blockbuster hieß der gibt jetzt mal doch
nach oben ich bin gespannt und ihr könnt
auch gerne in die kommentare schreiben
ich habe mich bei 150.000 volleren auf
youtube mich ungefähr ungenannt zu alex
wie früher hieß blog was da für die die
es nicht wissen schaut euch diese mails
an geil hier sieht man es vor vier
jahren habe ich das hochgeladen
20 fakten über mich hat glaube ich
damals jeder gemacht und ich würde sagen
wir klicken erstmal kurz drauf ja heute
so sah ich früher aus ein bisschen
verändert habe ich mich schon obwohl ich
sagen muss vom gesicht her passt das
natürlich noch zu
abgesehen von meinem extrem bartwuchs
heutzutage hat man da natürlich kaum
unterschiede
3000 like sie machte ich dislike wir
schauen uns mal die kommentare an
danke bruder
warum habe ich dann so viel selber
kommentiert darunter wer schaut es auch
erst 2017 immer noch das gleiche ich
will auch gar nicht lange lagern ohne
witz das ist glaube ich keine ahnung das
gehört einfach dazu so ich denke immer
okay heute was es mal schnell oder heute
la was du nicht so lange man fahren dann
fange ich an und bin am ende dann
trotzdem wieder bei eineinhalb minuten
leute so ist das leider tut mir leid
aber damit müsst ihr euch ab denn so was
sind denn hier die neuesten kommentare
vor zwei tagen wird kommentiert zwei
klicks für die die es nicht wissen meine
kanal url also so hieß meine channel
ganz am anfang ich habe mich sechs
genannten zwei klicks gibt euch zwei mal
also eine mischung aus zweck weil das
wort zweck war glaube ich das jugendwort
des jahres 2015 2014 oder zumindest in
der engeren auswahl
und ich dachte mir so einkommen zweck
und alex das kann man kombinieren zwei
klicks und das flex hat sich auch bei
vielen von meinen freunden echt richtig
eingebrannt ich werde manchmal swag lex
genannt alter dass wir über 2000 trägt
sind fast so leute dann will ich
natürlich gar nicht lange lagern und hus
wahrscheinlich schon jeder fünfte minute
und wir schauen einfach mal zusammen
rein in dieses wunderschöne kunstwerke
[Musik]
wer kennt dieses intro jeder von euch
oder und hier steht einfach zwei klicks
ja ich habe es dann nochmal umgeändert
zu alex wie irgendwann zwischendurch war
es nochmal blockbuster man musste sagen
das intro lied passt natürlich nicht an
dieser stelle das hat eine weile
gedauert bis sich dieses get lost
gefunden habe also dieses wort zittern
weil david tynan verwechsle ich habe mir
überlegt dass man erst hab ich überhaupt
hallo gesagt ach so vor dem intro und so
kann man es auch machen das video geht
drei minuten 28 unbedingt 21 fakten
video sein sollte dass diese ganze
geschichte ist schon ziemlich ausgelaugt
aber macht heute ein paar trotzdem ich
weiß nicht ich finde die musik viel zu
laut alt hat es ist viel zu laut man
hört man dies ja fast lauter als ich
aber solche banken videos richtig gut um
mich was erkennst du dir sag mal ich
weiß auch dass wir jetzt halt dass wir
nicht wieder schauen ich mich schon wo
ich dann halt ja und also diese videos
gemacht habe aber auch für die dafür
jetzt neu dazu
dazu kommen nicht wirklich genutzt mich
halt auch besser kennt da merkt man so
schon also erst muss ich sagen wie hatte
ich bitten die mütze auf es sieht ganz
süß aussah ich mal aber so ich würde
heutzutage niemals so die keb aufziehen
allein diese chicago bulls caps sind ja
mega auf die wahl 2013 aber richtig da
war ich richtig geheizt oder auch nur
jetzt wahrscheinlich gerade gehört ich
rede so ja 20 sekunden am stück und
verspreche mich ein- zweimal live heute
trifft das auf keinen fall merken also
wenn ich mich verspreche wenn wir das
raus geschnitten und neue gesagt
irgendwie ist man so perfektioniert
durch die jahre so wir schauen weiter
ich will auch nicht lange lagern und
wird direkt man sagen wir schon zum
ersten tag
wir sind jetzt hier bei sekunde 44 und
ich hab hier gesagt ich will jetzt gar
nicht lange an
meistens liegen wir heute so bei minute
1 30 also da habe ich mich wohl
verschlechtert ich bin 15 jahre alt und
werden sehen was er ist ja noch keinen
monat in dem ich nicht mindestens eine
woche erkältet war alter nicht stimmt
ich hatte früher meine zeit
ich glaube da war ich wirklich ein jahr
lang durchgehend erkältet mal stärker
mal nicht so stark aber ich hatte immer
schöpfen
aber jetzt bin ich wieder fit ich hatte
vor circa einem jahr mal lange haare und
sei einfach mal total scheiße aus
hollywood ich habe da runter geguckt und
wollte da eigentlich ein bild einbinden
da bin ich mir sicher
aber habe wohl vergessen ich esse pro
tag wirklich weiß ja jetzt war ich schon
17 mal da ich weiß um gelungen schon 17
mal in den sommerferien auf der gleichen
insel formentera
neben ivica übels geil und ich bin sehr
froh dass ich eigentlich jedes jahr
diesen luxus hatte sage ich mal dort
urlaub machen zu können weil es echt
schön ist und war bis jetzt auch noch
keine anderen insel die annähernd so
cool ist wie formentera wenn man party
machen will ist man da allerdings eine
falsche adresse
aber es bis zu acht stunden pro tag
kicker wie habe ich das denn gemacht das
geht doch gar nicht angenommen ich war
von 8 bis 14 uhr in der schule kommen 14
uhr wieder dann hätte ich ja wenn ich
acht stunden zocken möchte bis 22 uhr
durchgezockt das geht doch gar nicht ich
muss an dieser stelle auch mal sagen ich
glaube ich gar nichts mehr
ab und zu mal fifa weil ich sehr sehr
selten weil ich finde so diese sucht
nach irgendwelchen unnötigen
ballerspielen ist solle zeit war schön
aber es kann natürlich spaß machen aber
irgendwann ist es auch wieder vorbei so
und ich finde man kann diese zeit die
man vom computer sitzt und irgendwelche
games spielt so viel besser verbringen
ok weiter geht's
meinem pc irgendwas zocker sondern
einfach nur noch da die frau nicht
unbedingt wenig daran hänge aber das
auch nur weil ich halt gesagt ich bin
facebook-usern sich das ist jedenfalls
die junge da habe ich mich jetzt gerade
recht so ein bisschen fremd geschämt
weil ich ich sags mal so facebook und
instagram süchtig bin ich bin heute
nicht mal instagram wichtig ich bin auch
nicht youtube süchtig sollte ich jetzt
da gesagt okay ich bin youtube süchtig
weil ich gerne youtube videos schaue
hätte ich ja verstanden aber facebook
und instagram süchtig das wort hat ja
auch noch nie gehört ich erste pro woche
ungefähr so zweimal macdonald und
zweimal besser und das gut ist ich werde
gut erstmal muss ich noch mal kurz sagen
ich stelle mich in diesem video echt so
richtig schlecht da finde ich und das
mit dem zwei mal pizza und soll bei
mcdonald's trifft jetzt heutzutage nicht
mehr zu ich bin zwar das essen angeht
mittlerweile echt richtig verwöhnt und
es ist schwer sich mit gutem essen zu
überzeugen weil ich einfach hielt köln
so viele gute sachen kenne und auch
immer lecker essen gehe oder gerne mal
lecker essen gehe aber aber ich will
euch nicht es ist halt einfach so bei
mir ich bin da auch echte richtig
dankbar dass ich eigentlich essen kann
was ich möchte natürlich achte ich auch
darauf ab und zu mal gesunde sachen zu
essen aber wenn ich jetzt eine woche
durchgehend bis heißen würde oder
irgendwelchen fastfood krams würden wir
das auch nichts ausmachen
und so einfach die spotify charts von
130 runter und wieder hoch aber halten
beispiel so gamestar fälligkeit auf
jeden fall vor allem mit dieser mittel
haben wir geringster ich bin zwar schon
15 aber wir kommen das irgendwie
manchmal so vor als wäre ich erst fünf
der anderen seite kommt aber auch
manchmal so vor als wäre ich von den
vielen erwachsenen so werde ich es fünf
mehr zu bekommen als wäre er ist zwölf
hätte ich gesagt okay und ich sag mal so
ich würde mich in diesem video auf jeden
fall so 14.15 schätzen auch von dem was
ich sah gehälter auf jeden fall nicht
das wort gut heißt halt gut so wäre es
schlecht hieß es schlecht du trottel
welche youtube kann ich mich eigentlich
sehr gut aus leicht glaube ich so meinen
ersten kanal mit ungefähr 11 bis fünf
jahren erstellt habe irgendwann werde
ich dann ins fliegen gekommen und ich
glaube ich habe auf meinem letzten kanal
nach ungefähr ein halbes oder dritten ja
was 3000 abonnenten oder ein knapp 3000
abonnenten und auch eine partnerschaft
und eine partnerschaft okay man muss
dazu sagen es war früher ist sehr
besonders youtube partner zu sein man
hatte da so ein extra feature man hat er
seinen eigenen banner und so um
heutzutage ist es ja ganz anders ich
habe gerade gesagt dass ich ja jetzt
blöcke wobei das ist ja eigentlich
keinen block mehr block sind ja
eigentlich glaube ich nehme euch mit man
kann natürlich auch sagen ich blocke
über das thema aber ich finde es war
damals falsch nicht blockbuster zu
nennen weil ich eigentlich gar keine
blogs zu wenig gemacht habe
ich habe früher wirklich alles mit
apfelkompott vergessen oder apfelmus ich
muss auch gerade mal sagen seht ihr im
hintergrund diese poster von fc bayern
münchen ich war wirklich nie bei
empfängt ich habe zwar immer gesagt ich
bin bayern fan aber an sich macht sich
bei janney und warum diese poster daran
keine ahnung ich weiß noch nicht warum
ich meine brasilien vielleicht in meinem
zimmer hängen halt wieder früher mal
gedacht ja herr bist du brasilianer
nö ich habe wirklich noch nie geraucht
alkohol getrunken oder gesagt sagt alex
mit 15 das stimmt natürlich heute immer
noch und wenn ihr mir das nicht glaubt
dann müsst ihr jetzt diesen kanal
abonnieren es ist noch nicht gemacht
habe viel spaß ich glaube mein erstes
mal alkohol getrunken habe ich mit 15
gerade 15 war ich dort habe ich das
erste mal glaube ich dass ein oder
andere mineralwasser zu viel gespürt so
und das war es auch schon mit dem video
war immer noch dieses tanktop von
hollister das war es anscheinend mit dem
video ist auf jeden fall krass ich finde
ich habe mich schon ziemlich verändert
es war das allererste liga was ich auf
diesem kanal hochgeladen habe und wenn
man jetzt mal so drauf zu rückblick was
ich schon alles
hierdurch erleben durfte oder so und wir
sind jetzt fast 800.000 bald das ist
schon krass und freue mich natürlich
sehr und ich hätte da niemals gedacht
als dieses video gedreht hat dass das so
lange anhält oder dass ich das so lange
machen kann oder dass mir das auch so
lange spaß machen vor allem so
erfolgreich wird also danke an dieser
stelle ich bin morgen auf der miss
germany wahl im europa-park da freue ich
mich schon sehr drauf ein paar
attraktive
mit germany's zu sehen vielleicht den
einen oder anderen wir sehen uns sonntag
wieder da gibt es ein neues video hat
rein checks oder instagram